the second season of DC universes Titans
has given hardcore comics fans plenty of
hidden things to find their a meaningful
Pascoe's direct swipes from comic book
covers and mentions of unseen beloved
characters we're breaking down orders
and more in our roundup of Easter eggs
you might have missed in Titan's season
2 the gun Joe Chill used to murder Bruce
Wayne's parents make something of an
appearance in the Titans season 2
premiere Trigon subjects the Titans are
the same kind of visions he used on Dick
Grayson in the season 1 finale in the
case of Jason Todd he inserts a new
Robin into the end of dicks vision just
after dick has killed Batman dick tells
Jason that the younger hero is an animal
who needs to be put down their fight 10
- the infamous pistol sliding from his
broken case to the floor near Jason when
Jason crabs a gun a dick suggests Bruce
would never keep the gun loaded
what idea
does the Titans version of the Caped
Crusader
really keep Joe chills gun in the
Batcave like the Batman of Justice
League does Jason actually keep chills
gun loaded while he's living with Bruce
or is all this just part of the illusion
considering we know that in the comics
Jason taught eventually goes down some
dark roads including becoming the lethal
vigilante the Red Hood it's possible
that what he says isn't as part of
trigons nightmare if not it would not
only be a betrayal of Bruce Wayne's
trust but would point to a dark turn for
the character and the show equals what
happens in the comics just before Rachel
defeats Trigon in the Titans 2 season
premiere the possessed Titans wait
nearby with the dark splotching around
their eyes signaling their new loyalties
one shot in particular mirrors the cover
of a comic that marked one of the more
memorable battles between the Titans and
Trigon the cover to 1985's New Teen
Titans issue 4 shows the heroes standing
in a row with their altered eyes letting
us know they're under trigons control
the players aren't all the same the
covers of the comic shows Beast Boy Kid
Flash and cyborg also their eyes are
colored red rather than the skin around
their eyes taking on that inky black
look regardless the meaning behind the
respective eye effects are clear as is
the inspiration the show takes from the
comic in New Teen Titans issue for the
heroes are forced to individually
wrestle with trigons power just as they
are in the season 2 premiere rather than
being exposed to nightmare visions that
usually lead the heroes to making
horrible and often lethal choices the
heroes of New Teen Titans issue 4 fight
gray skinned red eye shadow versions of
themselves in the real world one of the
more interesting moments in the brief
scenes involving Slade Wilson aka
Deathstroke in season 2 so far is when
he enters a passcode to enter his
private Arsenal the conversation between
Slade and wintergreen suggests has been
a while since lead has been home and the
scene in the country store suggests
re-emergence of the Titans that has
brought him back when Slade in winter
green approached the Arsenal for a
moment it seemed Slade may have
forgotten the password
wintergreen offers to enter it himself
but Slade insists the code Iain says
five six three nine works and once you
see the code you may wonder if it was
his memory that was bothering him or the
code himself the password isn't just a
random grouping of numbers if you look
closely at the letters corresponding to
the numbers on the keypad it seems clear
that Bay's
named Joey Joey is a meaningful name in
the Deathstroke mythos as it's the first
name of the superhero Jericho stayed
Wilson's youngest son actor and activist
shel a man is set to play him in
upcoming episodes of titans the
beginning of season two not only sees
the Titans get a home but gives us the
appearance of one of TC comics heroic
monuments Titans Tower in most media
before now Titans Tower has usually been
represented as it was originally in the
comics as a giant t-shaped building it's
also hugely separated from the mainland
on its own Island we don't get quite the
same tower in Titans but the show does
pay tribute to the comic book version
though the tower clearly is made to look
more like a regular office building than
the t-shaped headquarters of the comics
when the camera pulls back from the
tower at the end of their season two
premiere the Titans living space is
highlighted while the shadow falls on
the bottom half of the building making
it look like a tea probably the most
blatant Easter Egg who's seen in tights
in season two but a second episode is a
phone call Donna Troy gets after she and
Corey handoff the villain shimmer to the
police as her phone rings she looks at
the screen and we see the name Roy
Harper pop up Roy Harper has had a
number of different superhero code names
over the years the most recent being
Arsenal he was once known as speedy
Green Arrow's sidekick
Coulson Haynes occasionally plays a
character on CW's arrow and in the
comics he was one of the many
superheroes to die in the miniseries
heroes in crisis could this be a
precursor to ask nor joining the Titans
there's no news about such an addition
but anything's possible it could be that
Donner and Roy are dating and that's the
reason for the phone call
or perhaps Roy was a member of the
previous incarnation of the Titans and
like everyone else in season two second
episode he has news about the emergence
of dr. light the third episode of titans
second season ghost has a little bit of
fun with DC Comics longtime competition
Hank dawn and Donna finally show up to
Titans Tower
to help hunt down dr. lights but they
aren't too happy when dick tells them
Deathstroke's daughter is chilling out
in a bedroom nearby surely after the
exchange a dick visits Rose in her
bedroom and brings her a black eye patch
to replace the white bandage she's been
wearing since she was introduced in the
previous episode later that night
Rosalyn characteristically friendly
conversation with Rachel in the Titans
kitchen Rachel tells Rose her name is
pretty
me too pretty now patch has a nice ring
to it likely the show's creative team is
having a little fun at the expense of
one of the more well transparent alter
egos in the history of comics sure
Superman is silly for thinking he could
hide his secret identity with nothing
but a pair of glasses but he's got
nothing on Marvel's Wolverine who took
on the least convincing alter ego ever
in the beginning of his first ongoing
solo series while in Southeast Asia
Wolverine wore a black iPad 2 navigated
the criminal underworld by calling
himself patch apparently thinking no one
would notice his trademark hair
nice try perch check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite DC
characters are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and to the bail so
you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]